KELLY O'BRIANT: Today
I'm giving a webinar
on Interactivity in Production.
This webinar is the third
in a three part series
that we've been doing last
month Garrett Grellman
delivered Reproducibility in
Production and Thomas mock
delivered RStudio
Connect in Production.
Those are freely
available on demand
at resources.rstudio.com
the same place this one will
be made available, but before
jumping into interactivity
in production, I wanted to
acknowledge some of the themes
from those first two
webinars that I'll
be touching on as well.
The first theme is production
means different things
to different people.
Garrett talked about
this, Tom talked
about this really well
with RStudio Connect
and how the connect product
can meet you where you are
and make production
available in different forms
with different meanings
to wherever you are
in your analytics lifecycle.
Also along the
same lines, RStudio
connectives this
publishing platform
for communicating impactful
data science work.
R Markdown, is a
tool for creating
computational documents and
communicating impactful data
science through either static
reports or documents that
have interactive
elements inside them.
And the one thing that I want
to use as a jumping off point
for starting our
discussion today,
is what Garrett introduced in
the reproducibility webinar,
which was the
interactivity spectrum.
So in this
interactivity spectrum,
Garrett made this case
for thinking strategically
about what level of
interactivity your data product
actually requires.
And meeting that level of
interactivity with the type of
experience that you
want to deliver in order
to communicate effectively.
So I really like this a
lot, but it does presuppose
that you know what you want
to build in the first place,
or you're at a point in your
iterative development work
cycle where you're willing to do
some introspection on what you
should or could be building.
This is important because
as you progress down
the interactivity
hierarchy, things become
more complicated to build.
And we tend to think
of Shiny applications
the highest level
of interactivity
as the most complex to develop.
Now, on the other side
of things Garrett also
spoke to this in his webinar, we
tend to see people learn Shiny,
and then use it for
just a lot of things.
Borderline on everything.
And I know I've done
this and it's very hard
once you commit to this
Shiny application workflow
or development cycle to
walk back from Shiny.
In other words, once you've
committed to using Shiny,
it's difficult to take a step
back and evaluate whether you
would be better served
delivering your desired user
experience in another format.
Now, all that being
said, I love Shiny.
So I want to talk about the
case for starting with Shiny
because I know that folks
out there do this too,
it's a great tool, it
makes things really easy
and it's a great tool
for doing a lot of things
like exploratory data
analysis, prototyping, fast
iteration through building tools
that other folks might want
to use and that you can use
to drive impact of your data
science work inside of
your own organization.
Now I know Shiny Wizard,
you can go and look
at the Shiny contest results we
ran last spring to see evidence
of actual Shiny wizardry,
but I'm comfortable enough
with Shiny that I can build
really powerful prototypes
in a short amount of time
and I know a lot of folks
are in that same boat.
So when I need to build a tool
that other people might want
to use too, my
natural inclination
is to start developing
that tool in Shiny.
Now these things
can quickly escalate
when you want to give access to
someone else to use that tool.
And that's what I want
to talk about today.
I think of Starting with Shiny
as the equivalent of writing
an hour long talk.
So I call Starting with
Shiny and local development
as the hour long talk
of data products.
And hour long talks
if you've ever
developed one can be
rambling, cluttered you have
a lot of time to work with.
So there can be parts
that work really well,
and parts that
don't work so well.
And I know I'm giving an
hour long talk currently,
so I hope that in
the questions you'll
let me know which parts
work well and which do not,
so that I can clarify those.
But the goal is when you're
taking this local development
asset into production,
is that you
want to turn that hour
long talk of data products
into the lightning
talk of data products.
So the difference between
hour long talks and lightning
talks are lightning talks are
these targeted really elegant
streamlined little
pockets of information
that you're trying to deliver
in a very short amount of time.
And the irony is
that it can take
a lot more time of your
own to develop a lightning
talk than it can to
develop an hour long talk.
So you have a lot
of space to work
with because these
lightning talks they just
need to have that
streamlined, that concision,
you need to get to your message
effectively and conclude
everything in the
right amount of time.
So maybe you start with
Shiny and local development,
and by the end
maybe in production
that original Shiny application
you had on your local machine
looks very different.
Maybe once you
get to production,
it's a group of assets that
complement each other maybe
it's a very different
kind of Shiny application.
As long as you're
evaluating along the way,
starting with Shiny in the
hierarchy of interactivity
is really OK by me.
So this is my agenda for the
webinar discussion today.
I started with making a
case for starting with Shiny
and now I want to
talk about when you're
taking a prototype of
a Shiny application
into production what I consider
the most important thing is.
And this is my perspective as a
solutions engineer at RStudio.
Then I want to talk about Joe
Cheng's most important thing
for shining in production.
Joe is, if you aren't
familiar the CTO of RStudio
and he was the creator
of the Shiny package.
After that I want to
talk about an example
a prototype app that I built
and then went through steps
that Joe outlines in
his performance workflow
to take that application
into production.
And along the way
I'm going to show you
what steps I took to
refactor and then evaluate
the impact of that application.
And finally reconsider the
hierarchy of interactivity
for what I've produced.
So let's jump right into it.
This is what I consider the
most important thing for running
Shiny in production.
And that is you need to
have a sandbox publishing
environment as part of your
development infrastructure.
This thing right
here, you need it.
It should be a place where
you can publish freely
into server that is
ideally configured to be
an identical twin of
your production server.
And this is your testing ground.
You can call it a sandbox,
staging, test server, whatever.
You need one of these.
If you only have one server
at your disposal in a pinch
even something
like this can work.
You can have the
same piece of content
be published to two
different destinations
on a single RStudio Connect
box, and have one destination be
reserved for production while
the other destination is
reserved for testing staging.
If you need any help
at all in your journey
to production advocating for the
right analytic infrastructure,
please reach out to us
at solutions.rstudio.com
where there are a
bunch of resources
for having these conversations,
or community.rstudio.com
in the R Admins channel.
And that's where a lot of
us on solutions engineering
like to hang out
and answer questions
coming from the community.
So two great resources there.
So that was my most
important thing.
Joe has a very
different perspective
and it's equally valid.
So these are two
awesome opinions
for Joe's Shiny in production
most important thing.
He highlights in this excellent
talk that he gave at RStudio
conf 2019, which
is also available
resources.rstudio.com/webinars
for you to watch.
This talk is excellent
and this is your homework
from this webinar, is to go
watch Joe's talk if you haven't
seen it already because it is
really that impactful if you
are doing anything that
involves Shiny in production.
So this talk was
the keynote where
he introduced the tools that
are Shiny engineering team here
at RStudio has been
working on to help support
bringing Shiny into production.
So it starts with going through
Shinytest, Shinyloadtest,
Profvis, plot
catching and async.
And he highlighted a
couple of these tools
throughout his
talk, but the thing
that's most important
to Joe, is Profvis
for Shiny in production.
This is a general
profile for our code,
but it's super important for
when you're bringing Shiny
applications into production.
A lot of prototype applications
fall over in production
because they contain these
performance antipodeans.
So it's important
when you're trying
to turn a prototype into
a production application,
to ask yourself
questions and suss out
whether your application
is suitable for production
in its current state.
So two questions you can
answer that are great
is, is this app fast
enough for production?
And then if it's not, what is
the cause of that performance
bottleneck?
So through the course
of Joe's keynote,
he goes through and looks at
an example application called
CRAN Whales that he created.
And covered how to make
that application faster
through the application
of these two tools.
Shinyloadtest to see if the
app is fast enough and Profvis
to see what in the
R code is making
that happen not fast enough.
So he lays out this excellent
performance workflow, which
is the real gem
here of this talk,
you ask if the app
is fast enough,
you test to see
what's making it slow,
and then three is you optimize
you solve those problems.
And the importance
of using Profvis,
is you can tell how passionate
Joe is about this when he talks
about it and in the
keynote he says,
you cannot guess what is
making your R code slow,
you do have to use this profile
or because your intuition about
what is making that
code slow it stinks,
it's garbage it's not good.
Even folks who are very
competent at building Shiny
applications can get tripped
up by simply assuming
you know what the problem is.
So Profvis, is just
an amazing tool
to help you get to
the optimization stage
and then make real impactful
changes to how your code works.
So in the spirit of Joe's talk
and his CRAN Whales application
success story I wanted to
build a similar application
for this webinar.
And I won't repeat the
performance work for a demo
that Joe has already
done and his, definitely
go watch it it's
really great seriously,
but I wanted to
create this prototype
to start that
would realistically
highlight some of those same
or similar performance anti
patterns.
So I have a CRAN Logs app that's
called the trending R packages
app.
And here's what it does.
As you can see here
in the screenshot
it has this table
it's dt table and you
can see which R
packages have been
trending over the last
period of time the top 10.
And then click on each
of these applications
to view a little bit of metadata
about what that package is
and what it does.
So all of this data is
coming from the CRAN Logs API
project plus a little bit of
our best magic scraping metadata
about each package.
So the workflow
that it goes through
is that I call out to the
CRAN Logs API slash trending
and point to get those
top 10 trending packages,
then I make 10 more calls
to that CRAN Logs API
to retrieve the download
counts for each package.
Put that data into DT
here in the application.
And then I use our best
magic to scrape out
that metadata about each
package when at the point
the user clicks on it.
So this app it
makes sense to me.
I'm constructing
this data as I go,
I'm not thinking about
scaling at this point.
Works pretty great in my
local development environment.
When I push it to my
staging server it works OK,
but I can already tell that
there is some danger here
as more users come to this
application I'm worried that it
won't be fast enough to
support the number of users
that I expect.
So at this point
I think to myself
this would be a great case
to activate Joe's performance
workflow and move through
Shinyloadtest and Profvis
to get the answers about
whether my application is
going to work in production and
how to fix it so that it does.
So I'll spare you the first
two points of the workflow.
Again go watch just
talk for those.
And skip to number three
where I'm optimizing my code.
So at this point,
the number one thing
that you do very
often to optimize
some of these
performance issues,
is to move work out of Shiny.
And Joe says there are
two important things
to consider when you're
moving work out of Shiny.
Things that you
don't want to do.
So you don't want
to do work in Shiny
while the user is waiting.
And the second
thing is, you don't
want to do the same work
for every user that's
very wasteful.
So he had this example
of loading the CSV
data into a Shiny application
every time a user connects.
And this application
I actually designed
for the purpose of highlighting
these two ethic patterns,
but it does a very
similar thing.
I am making 11 API requests to
the trending R packages table
to create that
data for the user.
And then once the user
is on the application,
I'm calling R best
two times to perform
that metadata scraping for
each row Selection that occurs.
So that would be repeating
that same work over and over
again for every user which
again, very wasteful.
So how do we solve this problem?
There are a number of ways I
can think of to solve this.
I could generate the
data ahead of time
and publish it in the bundle
along with my application code.
And this is a totally
valid workflow
and makes sense to do for a
lot of different types of Shiny
applications.
Sometimes you can just pull
the data together and throw it
in that bundle and send it along
as you're deploying to staging
to production and it's fine.
The problem here is
that I want users
to see the latest and
greatest trending R packages.
So literally an application
to explore trends.
So I don't want to get
stuck manually deploying
that new data or
cobbling together
or some CRAN job coupled with
a programmatic deployment
workflow that I then
need to monitor and make
sure it continues to work, I
just want new data delivered
to my Shiny
application that users
can see fresh information about
any time they visit the app.
So this is a great case
for adding R Markdown
to the equation.
I call this the
division of labor.
Using R Markdown to create an
ETL process to put that data
together and then host an output
file along with that report,
that I can then point my
Shiny application to consume.
So if you don't content
deployed to an end on RStudio
with an R Markdown
output metadata output
file in this case, in
the case of this image,
I have this report
called report title.
Very descriptive.
And it has an output file
that contains this data
that CSV files.
So in the course of
this report running,
it creates this data that
CSV file writes it out
and then it just gets hosted on
RStudio Connect alongside by R
Markdown report.
So if I'm running that
report on a schedule
that schedule is
producing this new data
dot CSV file lives
at this web address
and then I can point Shiny to
read in that data from the URL
hosted on my connect server.
So very cool.
And that's exactly what I want
to do for this application
in order to move that
work out of Shiny
and do it somewhere else
so that it doesn't have
to be in my Shiny code itself.
So this is what I built my
R Markdown Etl to generate
the same data frame
out of the making
calls to the trending API
and then making those R
best scripting function calls.
And I do this all
in an R Markdown
document, publish that
document to connect,
and then I schedule
it to run weekly
every Friday at a certain time.
And I can schedule that to run
a daily or monthly or hourly,
whatever schedule I want
to produce new data on,
I can do that directly
in the R Markdown
hosted on RStudio Connect
in the dashboard panel
that I'm showing here.
So really nifty tool to
create output data files.
So now I have these three
pieces of content here living
as my production
development package.
And I'm happy with the
performance of my Shiny
application because I've
moved that work out of Shiny
and into this ETL process.
So I have my
production assets being
this Etl in R Markdown, my
production application in Shiny
which is now fast and doesn't
repeat work for each user.
And then a third asset which
is not really a part of it,
but it is fun to publish
alongside as reference
information, which
is the Profvis
profile for that
production application.
So all of these three things can
live together and be a package
that I can feel confident about
running on my production server
and serving my
users effectively.
So at this point, am I done?
Am I making an impact
at my organization
through what I built?
How do I answer that question
is what I built correct?
You I have these two data
products shining in R Markdown
and working
harmoniously together.
Is there anything else to do?
So I'd like to take
a stab at trying
to quantify or track impact on
RStudio Connect with my assets.
So how do I know
that what I've built
is effective at communicating
my intended message?
The whole goal here was
to create something useful
and to drive users to find
insights through this tool
or make changes to how we
do work at organization
through communicating that
in Shiny and R Markdown.
So am I doing that?
Well, there's also tools
for getting that data off
of your Connect server.
And that is through usage of
another API called the RStudio
Connect instrumentation
data API.
And this is a
really cool feature
that Connect has that I
think is underutilized.
And so I want to use
this talk to encourage
you to look at some
of the resources
we currently have for
visualizing this type of data
on your connect server if
you have access to a server,
and explore different
variations building
tools that can give you insights
into how much impact you're
actually making through
these data products.
So RStudio Connect
records different types
of user activity for
different types of content.
You've got records for Shiny
applications about each visit
to that application and to
the duration of that visit.
And then you have records
of each visit for static
and entered content.
This dashboard you
see here on the right,
is one that my colleagues
on solutions that sharing
put together called the
Connect usage dashboard,
and it is available
at that GitHub URL.
The code is all there.
And we really encourage you
to take that you can drop it
into your own server
as is if you'd
like to see this same
information about your data
products, or you can
tweak it and make
it custom to see or
gather information that
will answer your own questions.
I've really been having a
fun time lately tweaking
this same
instrumentation dashboard
that my colleagues put together
and turning it into something
that I can answer questions
about individual apps.
So this is the same dashboard
driven by the same helper
functions that they
created, but I've
tweaked them just to look at
my production application.
And I want to know whether
this app is popular,
or whether this app is
just not driving traffic,
it's not being visited.
And I want to take actions
based on the answers
to those questions.
So if this application is
popular that's awesome,
I want to go to the runtime
for that application,
I want to evaluate
my load test and make
sure that I have the right
settings for our processes
and connections for
process so that my user
base is being served there.
And if the application
is not driving traffic,
it's not getting visits,
I want this dashboard,
which is an R Markdown
report to send me alert
and alert about that
information as well.
This app it's not
driving the desired
impact to the organization.
So maybe I need to rethink
what's happening there.
And I built this application
so that you can come in and set
a daily visit goal and then
set a session duration goal,
and you'll see here that based
on the inputs that I have
provided, my application
production app this CRAN Logs
trending R packages app
that I'm tracking here,
isn't hitting the total
session goal for daily count,
but it is hitting the average
session duration goal.
So one not so good,
one pretty good.
And these value boxes
will change color based on
whether or not I'm
hitting my goals.
Behind the scenes where
you don't see here,
is that this report
also contains code
to create a custom email alert.
Excuse me.
Based on these
value boxes as well.
So if over time I see that I'm
just not driving the traffic
to my CRAN Logs
application that I wanted,
this report will
capture that data
and send based on
what it finds it
will make a conditional
decision to send me
an email alert about
my underperforming app
or suppress that email.
So in this case,
it might send me
an email because my
app is underperforming
and that email is based
on a custom template
that I packaged along
with my R Markdown report
and it looks
something like this.
So I can have this email
come in and say, hey,
for this application tile we've
seen that traffic has been
chronically low, you might
want to consider communicating
the same information
if it's still
relevant in another format.
So think about whether
or not somebody is still
interested in interacting
with your Shiny application.
Is this the write
method of communicating?
Or why is this tool not having
the impact that I want it to?
Sometimes web
interactivity gets old.
Like somebody will
come to the dashboard
play around with
it once or twice,
but it's not that much fun or
interesting to click around
and they would rather have
that same information delivered
to their inbox on some schedule
so that they don't have
to go through the work of
interacting with the Shiny
application as funny
as that sounds.
Taking the steps to
go to the next server
and remember to
do that are steps
that some folks in your
organization or maybe
upper management are just not
going to take the time to do.
And so thinking about tailoring
the experience to your audience
is a really important part of
that whole process when you're
evaluating what you
put into production
should continue to exist there.
So some things you
might want to consider
to sacrifice Shiny runtime
in order to achieve
are you can have that parameter
eStart R Markdown that we've
seen in previous
webinars that gets
scheduled sends custom
emails like this one
to your management.
Scheduled email Report
Delivery I just said.
And then a third asset
that we didn't really
talk too much
about in the series
is creating programmatic
access to communicate insights
through the summer package
and developing REST APIs.
So all of these things
are perfectly excellent
alternatives to creating
more Shiny interactivity,
but they do take effort
in order to context switch
and refactor the
code that you've
invested time and energy
to create in producing
an alternative asset.
But I think overall it's
definitely a worthwhile process
to go through.
And that brings us back to the
hierarchy of interactivity.
So I think my key takeaway
here is let's definitely
think about how
you want to tailor
your experience to your audience
and in the process of doing
that remember that Shiny
applications do come
at a cost of complexity, you do
need to iterate through Joe's
performance workflow in
order to move prototype
applications into production
ready applications.
And in order to get
through all of that,
I would point to these
production building
blocks that we have made
available in different resource
formats here at RStudio.
So again, one more
shout out to Joe Cheng
and to the RStudio
keynote from 2019
it's an excellent talk about
shining and production.
And then individually
we have resources
that exist on either
subdomains sites
that we maintain here at
RStudio or open source package
reference sites that are
also available on GitHub
and externally to the RStudio
website on code profiling
through Profvis, general
information on version control
which is also an important
aspect of production,
testing through the
Shiny test package,
thinking about deployment
and release patterns.
And for that these resources
come from thought articles
that we've put on
solutions.rstudio.com access
and security for
those applications
also on solutions.rstudio.com
and performance
tuning looking at the
results of Shinyloadtest
and making tweaks to
your application code
and to your application
runtime settings
based on what your goals are.
So I hope you've enjoyed
this brief discussion
of thinking about the
interactivity hierarchy
when it comes to building assets
that include interactivity
like Shiny and putting
them into production.
I hope that you go and check
out some of these resources
and then continue the
discussion with us
at a community.rstudio.com
as well.
So here's one says what if
we don't have a subscription
to Shiny Connect?
So if you don't
have RStudio Connect
there are good
alternatives you can always
stand up in open
source Shiny server
as long as you have the
requirements to do so,
and we have plenty of
resources on Shiny.rstudio.com
about how to get
started doing that.
And a lot of these tools for
putting Shiny into production
with the open source
server will still apply
and some will be more
difficult to implement,
but either way there is a
path to sharing Shiny assets
without our pro products.
See what is required
to be able to share
Shiny app with co-workers
who do not have RStudio.
So today I talked a
lot about and a product
called RStudio Connect
and sorry if I didn't
put a lot of context around
that, you should definitely
go and watch Tom Mock's
webinar from two weeks ago
called RStudio Connect and
production, but like I said,
even if you don't go the
route of RStudio Connect,
we have other tools from
RStudio like Shiny server source
or even Shiny R pro if you're
interested in alternatives
there.
Here's one that says
could great could
the work could just
described be done
with a separate Shiny up run
on a schedule rather than the R
Markdown dock?
Now, Shiny applications
don't natively
work running on a schedule.
You have to interact
with them or have
some sort of programmatic
trigger to be able to do that
and they definitely
don't run out
of schedule on RStudio Connect.
So if you are trying to run and
Etl process on RStudio Connect
the choice for that
would be R Markdown.
Do the profiling tools work
for Shinyapps.io as well?
What are the
considerations there?
Yeah, so Profvis is just a
general profiling code tool.
So you can definitely
use that for R code,
you can use it for Shiny
code, you interact with it
on your local side.
So you're just profiling
that code in development
on the RStudio ID
or on RStudio Server
and then you're using
that information
to tweak your code,
which then will end up
living on Shinyapp.io or one
of the other servers products.
Yeah, so that's a great question
and is kind of the problem
that Joe addresses with the
CRAN Whale app and his talk
and voted.
So that does the
data get related
whenever a new user
opens the web address
and that's going to
depend on where you've
put that action in your code.
So you definitely don't want to
reload the data for every user
and you probably want to try to
utilize a drill down approach
for exposing access to
more data as it's required
for that user if possible.
We have a great example
of building an enterprise
dashboard with that
drill down approach
that my colleague Edgar put
together on db.rstudio.com.
That's db four databases
dot RStudio dotcom.
So that could be a really
helpful resource for you
when you're trying to
build an application that
loads a large amount of data.
Thanks so much.